look let's be honest derek jacobi only
playing the master for one episode of
new doctor who was always a waste but
Big Finish
looking to rectify it
[Applause]
I sigh affair how to replace the battery
in this thing anyways so I have gone in
a slightly different direction with Big
Finish this time I've moved away from
some of the older stuff the early stuff
and looked at something fairly recent
the war master box set
I guess it's counting a series one now
because they're gonna do at least three
more of these things
no promises I'm doing those right off
because the first thing to point out
about the box sets as opposed to most of
the stuff that I've talked about
previously when I've talked about Big
Finish which were single individual
stories is that it is way more expensive
so I can thank my patreon supporters not
only for selecting this particular
option but also if I didn't have the
back ending of my pager and supporters
I'm not sure I could have justified the
expense at least not before knowing how
good it was because yeah this is pretty
dang good so I'm trying to think of the
best way to even cover this because as a
box set there are four stories in it but
there's also an arc and a bit of a
continuous thing going across the four
stories but they do still all work
that's fairly individual pieces maybe
not the last one because last one is
very much a combination of what came
before but certainly the previous three
work as pretty you know complete story
experiences in and of themselves all
centered around in some way
Derik Jacoby's version of the master now
officially dubbed the war master so this
is the master during the period of which
the time oiss have revived him and he is
in some way involved in the time war at
this point whether he is acting
completely on his own or whether he is
in some way I'm supposed to be working
on behalf of the Time Lords is not made
entirely clear one suspects that the
master really can't help but self serve
no matter what the context is going on
for the most part but I'm gonna avoid
spoilers as much as as possible because
if you can afford this I do recommend it
and I know you know big finish's I can't
count on everyone having you know heard
these the way that I can with episodes
of the show we start out with a story
called
under the visco which is the most
straightforward of these it is it has
the master basically trying to retrieve
his own crash TARDIS and masquerading as
the doctor in the process hoping that
the doctors reputation will help him get
in basically a better position with the
folks that he needs to manipulate in
order to get what he wants at the same
time that he is trying to duck out on
the Daleks whom he cut a deal with that
he has no intention of honouring which
is just as well because everyone honor
their end of things
anyways their Daleks but watching that
play out and hearing derek jacobi he he
does the master I mean his master is the
most expertly manipulative version of
the master that I think I've seen it all
I'd like probably since Delgado
definitely and and you just though the
presentation that he puts forward to
convince people that they should trust
him is quite impressive and especially
when it turns cuz it has a number of
points when it turns the next one that
follows up on this one is called the
good master which is not entirely what
it sounds like because you think oh god
they turned him into a good guy and
that's one of the things about this set
overall which is that it's always risky
doing something focused on a villain
where the villains actually your
protagonist because I've I've listened
to you know Big Finish villain centric
stuff before and but even something like
I'd avarice is about what how he became
what we knew him to
so you could you could still work with
that but to have some have a character
who is a villain in the timeframe that
we've seen I mean you're having him at
the point where he needs to still be the
you know as bad as we've ever seen him
but have him be your main character
that's really tricky to make work and
they find some really interesting ways
to do it and get around the usual
problems with that because the standard
problems with something like that are in
order to have you you know not going why
would I be root for this guy he's the
worst thing ever
oftentimes these sorts of stories end up
softening the villain in such a way that
they're become more of an antihero than
a villain and while the doctor is
certainly the protagonists are the
doctor the master is certainly the
protagonist of the story overall it
never feels like they cheapened or
softened who he is in fact at various
points across these stories we get
notable reminders of precisely how he
who he is and how he tends to be at the
same time there are some really
interesting relationships that played
the big one being the one that gets
established in this second story the
good master which is with a guy by the
name of Cole now Cole is I believe has a
he's a med medical engineer I forget his
exact title but he he was a guy who
almost died and the doctor managed to
save and they and he kind of becomes the
Masters de facto companion over the
remainder of the stories now that
dynamic is a little bit different than
the doctor in the campaign which again
is really interesting that they set up
the dynamic that were you seen with the
doctor but allow it to be the different
beast that it would have to be if it's
gonna be the master instead of a doctor
but coming back to the good master it's
an interesting one because it kind of
poses the question because again he's
hiding and he's masquerading as you know
something that he isn't which is in this
case he's not pretending pretending to
be the doctor but he's pretending to be
a doctor and a surgeon and he's helping
people
it brings in interesting questions about
the validity of good actions taken by
immoral people for bad reasons because
even though he's doing it to maintain
his cover the master is saving people's
lives repeatedly and it brings up it
doesn't dive too deeply into them but I
do like that it kind of touches on that
question and then the following story
the sky man kind of looks at the
opposite end of that what happens when
the best possible intentions result in
less than ideal outcomes so the sky man
is I would say is the strongest of the
set and it is really heavy it's like
Black Mirror heavy it feels like it
feels like doctor who meets black mirror
and the basic premise I'll tell you the
starting premise on this so at this
point Cole is traveling with the master
and the master you know he's he's
explained to Cole you know the the war
is so much bigger than you think it is
look at all these planets these are all
gonna be destroyed and closes well you
have to do something a master says I
absolutely do not have to do anything
and there's no point in trying and Cole
says we'll let me try let me try and
help let me try and save something and
the master it's a wonderful moment he
just shows him a map of all these
planets that he knows are gonna be
destroyed because as a Time Lord he
understands you know the function of
time and the things that are going to
happen or possibly even have already
happened depending on how you how you
look at time he goes okay all these
planets are doomed pick one and try and
save it and just just that statement
pick one send a sends Cole into this
wait how am I supposed to even pick
something and you get almost immediately
what the Masters
kaien kind of put him through in terms
of challenging his convictions of going
in to save the day and it's the real
brilliance of the sky man is the pacing
of it it is gloriously paced and
perfectly built up as coal attempts to
help these this sort of very I was gonna
say unsophisticated but they've kind of
chosen to not advanced technologically
because that keeps them off the radar of
the people involved in the time war but
they they have you know very basic lives
but they are they are dying they are and
they are in danger and Cole tries to
help and we see the relationships he
builds the the care that he has we see
what is driving every step of this
process and we just get to see where it
goes and where it goes is yeah yeah you
know what this and you know it reminded
me of a little bit it's like the world's
most depressing version of the Star Trek
next generation episode inner light that
was the one where Captain Picard like
gets knocked into a coma and like has
this whole simulated memory of living on
this planet that is ultimately doomed
and you know living among these people
and having a family and all this stuff
but ultimately you know all these people
are just dead and he's just sort of tade
this is this is their way of imparting
the memory of their civilization into
somebody and and when I say it's similar
I mean like the general mood the whole
sort of person who has higher and
knowledge stuck in the civilization
trying to help try to move things
forward for them but as opposed to you
know the the slightly sad sight in
melancholy but ultimately sort of
touching way that inner light turned out
the sky
man is not bad so yeah really good
really good really affecting really
unsettling that one then we end on the
heavenly paradigm which like is that is
very much the culmination of all of the
stuff that's come before so the heavenly
paradigm has the doctor and Cole
basically trying to retrieve a Timelord
device that the that I'm sorry that I
keep saying the doctor the master and
Cole I'm trying to retrieve a no version
of the doctor makes an appearance in
this so any time I accidentally slip up
and said the doctor I mean the master so
the master and Cole are trying to
retrieve a Timelord device that the
master believes he can put to a use that
will and the entire war and they are
trying to retrieve it from this from
this suburban home in 1970s England
which you know being Time Lord
technology what's inside the house is
not what you would expect but there's
there's some cool little sort of twisty
bending miss going on and there's a
there's some really great interactions
between the master and the person that
they find inside that house and it ends
I think kind of how this sort of series
had to end in terms of where characters
end up how things wrap up and the
overall vibe of the thing I am gonna get
into spoilers in just a minute but the
last thing I'll mentioned I really love
the theme song that they created for the
war master it is it is this dirge war
drum like inverted version of the Doctor
Who theme but it's it's really cool and
everybody on in this is great I mean
Derek Jacobi is great and he plays the
the different sides and facets of the
master in terms of you know
who he pretends to be and who he really
is and coal is great he's a terrific
heir to the wonderful earnestness to him
I mean his his performance chemistry but
Jacobi is is terrific and all of the
other kid like every story had highlight
guest characters so it's it's really
well-done the production values are
great I burned through this pretty much
as a binge because I could not stop
listening to it it's really good and I'm
gonna have to talk a little bit more
about spoilers in three two one
so the casualness with which the master
kills coal is jarring in the best way
and like you should see it coming and I
think I think I did I did suspect that
the master was going to ultimately kill
coal i I didn't expect such callousness
in it though because I kind of expected
you know him to go oh you know III am
gonna miss you but this is something I
have to do no none of that he just does
it oh there you go my boy and he's gone
and that is just the perfect reminder of
who the master is and how he operates
anyhow you should have seen it coming
because at the end of that first story
into the visco you've got this really
like I say brutal and you don't even see
it but like the audio the screams are
Wow
when the master kills this this woman
who had been helping him and you know
she even gets on the TARDIS and you
think oh maybe she's going to travel
with him now and he just kills her not
for any particularly practical reason
but because he doesn't want to bring her
along where he's going next you know he
makes a
makes it clean oh well I can't humans
are forbidden there but like he just
didn't want to this guy's not a rule
follower and he kills her because that's
easier and it's derek jacobi is so good
at portraying this softer personality
that the master will fake that when you
have it for a long strip when you're
with it long enough especially like with
it with his a relationship with Colin
his their interactions with Cole you
can't help but buy into it a little bit
and so then when he when he turns which
he does because he has to because he's
the master cuz he can't he is incapable
of doing something that doesn't also
benefit him I mean he if whatever's
gonna give him the better result and for
a time what was gonna give him the
better result was having cold with him
and then eventually was gonna give him
the better result is if Cole is dead and
now Cole's dead that's it that's just
how it works with this guy and it is a
coldness that he hides so well when he
is not wishing to tip his hand and it's
really it's also really interesting it
it adds it helps bring back the the
Menace and the fear of the master
because part of the problem with the
master as a character is pretty much
aside from stuff like this all we've
ever seen him do is appear in Doctor Who
and whenever he appears in doctor who he
is foiled by doctor and it becomes the
same problem that every single long-term
recurring villain in every long-form
narrative medium has which is they lose
every time
eventually that that's just on Timah
dating anymore but to see what happens
and to see what the master is capable of
when the doctor isn't there to stop him
not that every
plan that the master has goes off
completely without a hitch or exactly as
as he intended but first of all the guys
got backup plans he knows what he's
doing but then even beyond that you know
he will still do massive damage even if
you know what the outcome that he gets
isn't exactly what he wanted just to see
him basically run rampant in the absence
of the doctor is kind of terrifying and
it this is just so masterfully done and
coming back to the sky man the the
progression of that from I'm here and I
want to help I'm I've really care about
you and your father in this community
here try this
okay I'll tweak it and do this no you
have to let me do this no please why are
you doing this to me no I'm doing this
to help you let me do this and the
lengths that he goes to before he
realizes what a horrible mistake he has
made and you can see it coming I mean
you can see that what he's doing is not
only not gonna save these people it's
probably gonna make things worse
and that happens to the nth degree and
it's just so well executed the
performances of everybody in that story
and like I said the pacing the
progression it spends just enough time
at each step along this path along this
road to hell paved with good intentions
every step on that road is perfectly
paced it is they're just long enough to
get you the exact you know feeling about
these characters about the situations
that any to and then it moves forward
because if it had lingered too long on
any one of these moments then it would
have been a slog and if it had done them
any shorter than it was then it wouldn't
have had the same emotional resonance it
is like I don't I don't know if people
will have ambitions to do
Oh dramas anyone who has an ambition to
write or try and produce audio dramas
needs to listen specifically to the sky
man for a masterclass on pacing it's
amazing and it's depressing man oh man
I think I'll wrap up there there aren't
too many specific spoilers that I feel
the need to go into on on the other two
like I could spend a lot more time going
into details and you know talking about
some of the more outlandish concepts
that I always love when they turn up in
Big Finish some of the more surreal
things like like the heart of the planet
and this whole you know the whole thing
with the house where that's that's in
the heavily heavenly paradigm and the
way kind of shifts and isn't logical and
just these kinds of things being in Big
Finish that you know you don't see in
the show necessarily because they are
hard
and abstract and really difficult to
visualize in a way that sells it whereas
you do in an audio your brain does it
for you
and they don't have to worry about how
much money it will cost them to try and
visualize some of these ideas it's this
is really great I mean it's really
terrific and I eventually at some point
I'd like to hear all the all the other
ones that are gonna come out I can't
really I'm yeah I don't think I'm gonna
buy them like as soon as they're out you
know I've got other stuff to try as far
as the Big Finish stuff goes I've got
quite a stuff quite a bit of stuff I've
already bought that I just need to
listen to but this was a kind of a
singular listening experience because it
walks that line of having a quote
unquote protagonist who is also the
villain and it doesn't soften him it
keeps him as what he needs to be and it
just
works so the war master only the good
have you heard it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
buttons and links and things that you
can push including a link to the patreon
which I mentioned already so check them
out if you feel like it if you don't
don't worry about it because you are the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]